All right, so Dec-POMDPs give us a way
to optimally trade off acting and
coordinating and communicating,
and I think we can now move on to
the topic of coaching, so
communicating and coaching.
So let's imagine instead of
the scenario we talked about before,
where we had an agent that
himself wanted an apple and
wanted to somehow use communication to
help bring about a positive outcome.
Let's look more particularly at this
case of, okay, agent 1 needs agent 2 to
learn a particular task,
like how to fetch an apple, all right.
And so what we're going to try to
do is figure out how can agent 1
convey the task to agent 2.
If agent 2 has its own reward function,
it has its own task.
So we're going to try to create
a a task or reward function for
agent 2 in some way that is
consistent with agent 1's goals.
>> Okay, so two things.
One, so when you said, we're going to
try to create, you mean like agent 1
should try to create a reward
function for agent 2, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Or to convince agent 2 to create
such a reward function on its own.
>> Okay, and so second, I think
the first thing agent 1 should do
is not tell agent 2 that he's trying
to teach him to fetch things.
I think he should probably.
>> Yeah, fetch is not going to happen.
>> Right, you should probably
use another nicer word.
But okay, I think I'm with you.
>> Yeah, that's why I said get.
>> Yeah, except you said fetch.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah,
it felt like fetch was a good word.
All right, yes, okay, so
I agree with you on that.
>> Okay, good.
So okay, so
then I think I've got the task.
I want to somehow get agent to
get a reward function that will
get it to solve some task that
I wanted to solve or him.
>> Yeah, exactly, and so there's a bunch
of different ways of thinking about
this, but we're going to dive into
a particular one that I think is really
interesting and actually quite useful
called inverse reinforcement learning.
>> What, okay.
>> All right, so
let me set this up for you.
>> All right.